digamos que tenemos una tubería
horizontal y del extremo izquierdo esta
es el área transversal a uno y va a ser
igual a dos metros cuadrados esta
tubería horizontal se va a ir ajustando
un poco de manera que en el extremo
derecho vamos a tener un área
transversal 2 igual a medio metro
cuadrado
también digamos que tenemos cierta
velocidad a la entrada de esta tubería
que es de 1 y también tenemos una
velocidad de salida llamada de 2
la presión externa
que se aplica hacia la derecha de la
tubería en la entrada es de 1
p uno va a valer 10.000 pascales
y la presión en el extremo derecho la
presión externa que va así se llama
presión 2 y esta va a valer 6000 pascal
es
en esta información y sabiendo que
tenemos agua que está fluyendo en la
tubería y que ésta es un ruido laminar
es decir que no existe ningún tipo de
fricción en el líquido ni turbulencia ni
nada por el estilo
teniendo todo lo anterior lo que quiero
hacer es calcular cuál es el flujo a la
entrada de agua en este extremo y qué
tanto volumen de agua por segundo entra
o sale de ese tubo ya sabemos que los
volúmenes de entrada y salida son
iguales debido a la ecuación de
continuidad
sabemos que el fluido
es el volumen entre el tiempo o es lo
mismo que la velocidad de entrada por el
área de entrada entonces es 2 que es el
área por el volumen de entrada y esto
también va a ser igual a el volumen de
salida que es un medio el área por la
velocidad de salida
podemos describir esto como de uno igual
un medio de r del flujo y también
podemos escribir que b2 es igual a dos
veces este flujo y de inmediato nos
damos cuenta que v2 está saliendo con
mayor rapidez que b1 simplemente viendo
el tamaño de las aberturas de estas
áreas y también sabemos que la presión
en la entrada es mayor que la salida y
que el agua viaja de izquierda a derecha
el diferencial en la presión va hacia la
derecha por lo que el agua va a ir en
esta dirección
entra por acá y va a salir
usaremos la ecuación de bernal y para
encontrar cuál es el flujo que pasa por
la tubería y vamos a recordar esta
ecuación de bernouilli y la vamos a
escribir aquí tenemos que la presión de
entrada 1 más la densidad del líquido
por la gravedad por la altura 1 más la
mitad de la densidad
por la velocidad
1 al cuadrado
va a ser igual a la presión de salida 2
más la densidad por la gravedad por la
altura a la salida más un medio de la
densidad por la velocidad de salida al
cuadrado
esta tubería está nivelada la altura en
ambos extremos es la misma así que h1 va
a ser igual a 0 por lo que ambos
términos de aquí los podemos ignorar ya
que este va a ser igual a este otro
podemos restar ambos lados por este
término y nos quedaría aprovechamos y
sustituimos los valores nos quedaría la
presión 1 que es 10.000
pascal es más la mitad de la densidad
por velocidad 1 que es un medio de r un
medio de r
al cuadrado es igual a la presión 2 que
son 6000 pascal es
más un medio de la densidad por la
velocidad 2 que es 2 f 2 r al cuadrado
ahora simplificamos esto restamos 6.000
en ambos lados y nos va a quedar 4000
más densidad
por r al cuadrado aquí 2 al cuadrado es
4 por 28 entre 8
igual estamos esto nos queda sacamos
esta 2 por 244 entre 2 nos queda 2 no
por efe por el flujo al cuadrado
multipliquemos a ambos lados de la
ecuación por 8 y nos va a quedar 8 por 4
r al cuadrado igual a 2 por 8 16 rock r
al cuadrado
ahora restamos roble real cuadrado en
ambos lados y nos va a quedar 32.000
igual a 16 o al cuadrado menos o al
cuadrado va a ser igual a 15
r al cuadrado y que es rojo recordemos
que es la densidad del agua y en un
vídeo anterior vimos que esta densidad
del agua rock es igual a 1000
kilogramos por metro cúbico
así que dividimos ambos lados
entre 15 porro
nos va a quedar
32.000 entre 15 por ron igual a r al
cuadrado y ya vimos que 15 porro es
igual
32.000 entre 15 x 15 mil
qué es lo mismo a 32 entre 15 por lo que
lo voy a escribir de este lado en otro
color
nuestra
es igual a la raíz cuadrada de 32 entre
así que sacamos nuestra calculadora para
encontrar el valor 32 entre 15
y a esto le sacamos la raíz cuadrada y
nos queda 1.46
así que r va a ser igual a 1.46 metros
cúbicos sobre segundo
este es el volumen de agua que entra o
sale del sistema en un segundo dado
también podemos calcular las velocidades
ya que están en función de este flujo
por lo que mi velocidad de entrada base
es la mitad de r mi velocidad 1 es la
mitad de 1.46 va a ser aproximadamente
punto 73 metros
por segundo y la velocidad de salida es
el doble de esta cantidad por lo que
será unos 2.8 metros por segundo
espero que se les haya ayudado a
comprender mejor estos conceptos y esta
ecuación de berlín y nos veremos en el
siguiente vídeo donde hablaremos algo
sobre termodinámica